hallo mein name ist luca und das hier
ist tief und steve ist ein bisschen dumm
die fed ihr einen brief bekommen vom
museumsdirektor und zwar dass dieses
erste arbeitstag im museum das tief
allerdings ein wenig tollpatschig ist
ist es vielleicht keine gute idee dass
er hier in diesem museum arbeitet
allerdings sehen wir schon drei pfeile
hier unten auf dem boden war sie einst
war sie zwei und irgend so ein komischer
stein panels steve kann sich jetzt
entscheiden welche weise er nimmt das
heißt ich würde sagen wir einfach mal zu
dieser phase hin und jetzt hat steve die
vase in der als tief bleibt stehen ich
drücke nichts meine damen und herren
steve taumelt so hin und her ich muss
mal ganz kurz eben einfangen
ja wie gesagt tiefes leicht tollpatschig
auf jeden fall ist dies aufgabe jetzt
diese phase zu nehmen und irgendwohin zu
tief soll diese phase nun dort vorne hin
bringen und dabei darf ich so wenig
dinge hier umrahmen wie es ihnen geht
ich finde aber das habe ich ganz gut
hingekriegt also sie stellt die wahl
setzt darauf tief nein nein nein nein
steve die wir starten das ganze mal von
vorne wir entscheiden uns diesmal für
das ding hier vorne und jetzt sehen wir
auch schon davor dass der feind wenn ja
das hat ja vorhin noch gar nicht richtig
funktioniert also hier geradeaus laufen
steve du hast ein paar zukunft und im
handgelenk hier vorne rum um mein gott
das war relativ eng steve jetzt 433 gott
sieht man was hast du denn auch für
komische beine hier vorne müssen wir um
freunde das ist schwierig sie aus die
man wieso willst du denn so dumm hier
vorne jetzt diese stein dingen darauf
gestellt haben was drauf gestellt freuen
und jetzt auf einmal läuft sie froh bald
werde
du bist ein mensch der welt obwohl ich
das ja eigentlich bin
jetzt nehmen wir uns mal diese hier
vorne und sehen schon da hinten nun
einen roten pfeil eingeblendet es sieht
noch sehr sehr gut hier aus allerdings
komme ich schon die ganze zeit gegen den
gast eve das ist doch nicht ein
verdammter ernst kommen jetzt bewegt
deine füße jetzt ein bisschen und jetzt
hier rückbank ein bisschen abbremsen
nach vorne wieder abbremsen steve ihr
fordert durch nein nein nein wir stoßen
ihn nichts ohne stiefel ein ok genau
hier vor noch um ganz einfach das ist ja
relativ simpel so du stellst es jetzt
hier vorne drauf einfach nach vorne
fahren
wir haben positiven score das ist für
mich ja schon mal was gutes
ey
acom
kommen das ist nicht ein scheiß ernst
hier ein positiver scores auf jeden fall
was gute freunde
die steuerung ist relativ simpel man
muss nur gegenlenken der quasi war
gewackelt von alleine wo muss die denn
jetzt sind
oh ja und acht da oben er wackelt von
alleine man muss ein bisschen
gegenlenken
ich glaube die vase die man selber in
der hand hat kann man jetzt nicht fallen
lassen sondern man kann höchstens
irgendwelche anderen sachen andrea steve
steve shill ich weiß nicht was passiert
wenn ich jetzt volle kanne gegen die
wand gehen jeder passiert nichts hier
vorne hoch das heißt sie kann eigentlich
nichts passieren okay das heißt hier
vorn haben ein paar banden das ist alles
was man machen muss
also man kann nicht springen man kann
nicht irgendwas schlagen oder
wegschießen oder so man muss einfach nur
steve mit der base helfen das hier ist
schon relativ engen freunde und mein
gott ok steve lipscomb prinzip
zurückkommen
dass man nochmal ob mein gott ok ok
bleibt stehen bleibt stehen die bleibt
stehen du glaubst du bestehen bleibt
stehen
das ist nicht das ist doch nicht wahr
das ist nicht wahr da können wir hier
aber zumindest nichts mehr kaputt machen
auf der rechten seite das heißt wir
gehen hier rechts ein bisschen rum jetzt
hier links gut ausgewichen steve und
jetzt hier vorne einfach nur das ding
ablegen einfach nur ablegen da
score von 1000 jetzt können wir uns
einfach auf mail new klicken klicken
wieder auf start sind wieder und
am
es gibt tatsächlich noch einen level ich
weiß ich aber ebenfalls zu verstören
unterwegs seid wenig freuen aber ich hab
früher oft darüber nachgedacht wie es
wohl wäre oder wie es wohl wäre würde
ich mir ja sagen wenn man einfach einen
fußball bekommen würde und dann in seine
schule gehen können und einfach alles
kaputt ballern könnte alle fenster alle
gegenstände will wenig verstörend oder
habt ihr so was auch mal gedacht das ist
quasi das was ich gerade mache freunde
also ich glaube wir ein bisschen rum
heute einfach mal jede war so um die es
irgendwie um
ja
also es richtig drei wochen später
hier ist alles umgehauen hier vorne da
hinten stehen noch ein paar sachen aber
da rechts ist auf jeden fall auch alles
umgehauen
das ist ein wundervolles spiel an der
stelle wo ich das heute gewinne jetzt
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren steve hat ein bisschen verkackt
würde ich sagen wenn euch dieses spiel
gefallen hat meine damen und herren das
gerne mal einen like da schreibt mir
andere dumme spielen die kommentare die
ich eventuell das nächste mal zocken
kann und jetzt kommt das auto glas
wasser
das war es jetzt hier vom video ihr
könnt jetzt hier mal den kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
schenken ihr findet ihr zwei andere
videos und weniger abonnenten zeit könnt
ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]